-You need to prove you're looking for work
-Yeah I've been looking, trust me
-Three signatures by tomorrow
or you can tell it to the judge
-Tell me about a time when you
worked hard to solve a problem
-This morning, getting up
-We're gonna find you someone you like
-Let me be your arms and your legs
- I love that
-Alright
-Penthouse
-You need to wait your turn
-Relax. It's not a holdup.
Just sign this for me please.
- How would I sign it?
- I don't know. Slowly?
- Don't your arms work?
- They don't.
- You can move your mouth.
- As can you.
- I need assistance.
- How much is the pay?
-Hell yeah man!
Hell yeah!
-It's my bad,
my bad, man
-You are not qualified for this position
-The buckle! Buckle
- Have you ever changed a catheter?
- Nah
-Pinch the head, insert.
-I can't feel it.
-Well, I can.
-You wanna feed your soul?
Then listen to what's cool.
"Think, think, think about
what you're trying to do to me"
-It's amazing ain't it?
I sound just like her.
-Yeah, it's uncanny.
- You as rich is Jay-Z?
- No, richer.
- Which car is yours?
- All of these to the right.
- Oh my God.
- They're not practical
-Exactly!
-Wooooooo!
-You can have any girl you want.
What about this lady with all the botox?
-You'll be perfect for each other.
You can't move your body,
and she can't move her face.
-Surprise!
-I specifically said nothing for my birthday.
-I'm sorry you got to have a
surprise party in your huge mansion.
Someone's got real problems.
- I'm fighting to see my son.
- And whose fault is it?
Is it yours or is the world
out to get you?
-Are you mad?
You wanna break this big-ass bottle of wine?
-Yes!
-What else you wanna do?
-The bull!
-What–
-Dell made a mess
-Just relax!
-I am relaxed!
This is me being relaxed!